against all odds a baby pulled from the
wreckage of flight said nine to 100 is
rushed away from the crash scene to be
assessed by doctors no sooner had it
taken off flight data records show the
plane lost altitude struck a concrete
barrier and hits a two-story building
this is where the 95 passengers and five
crew ended up remarkably more than 60
people survived we just took off from
the ground after several seconds the
plane started like like a bull swing at
the same time started vibrating very
badly and as soon as it gets a little
higher the vibration and the sound of
the engine the soaring sound of the
edges starts getting louder at some
point going downwards so at that time I
realized that we're 100% will hit the
ground once the plane hit the ground it
was like a team can looks as if someone
starts squeezing the team can't very
fastly and it came till the 14th row I
was sitting on the 15th row it came to a
14th row and I saw that there was a guy
sitting on the 14th row that all the
ceiling came on him like smashing on him
with all its like power queues to donate
blood to the injured stretched outside
the nearest hospital 2/3 of those on
board survived as well as medical help
all have required psychological support
for trauma
we had 19 patients one after another
brought to our clinic by ambulance all
the patients are seriously traumatized
at the moment psychologists are working
with both relatives and patients the
airline Becca is Kazakhstan's first
low-cost operator the plane itself was a
medium-sized to twin turbo jet airliner
manufactured by the dutch company Fokker
that went bankrupt in 1996 we can say
preliminary findings have shown the
aircraft touched a runway with its tail
twice a technical investigation that's
being led by the interstate aviation
committee will be establishing whether
this was pilot error or technical issues
while the course of the crash is
investigated all of the airline's
flights have been suspended this is the
tail in other words a fin and these are
the elevators of this aircraft which was
a Fokker 100 aviation expert Mike Vivian
isn't surprised by how the plane handled
the impact I suspect it landed fairly
flat it didn't get very high 50 to 100
feet maximum and I suspect he came down
and a fairly flat attitude clearly it
didn't come down a nose attitude because
it would have been much more severely
damaged if not disintegrated well the
names of those who lost their lives
emerge a local news organization has
said their editor-in-chief Donna
kruglova
is among the dead described as an honest
and courageous investigative journalist
she was travelling to celebrate the new
year with her parents
given the high speed impact of the crash
it is remarkable that more people
weren't killed having only just taken
off with its fuel tanks full had the
plane caught fire it's unlikely anyone
would have survived
Katie Spencer Sky News